bonsoir et bienvenue nouvelle édition du
78 en direct à 18h pour faire le point
sur l'actualité locale sur TVfil 78
invité de ce lundi 24 septembre Chantal
Pauli texi est la fondatrice et
présidente d'agisser contre la violence
morale intrafamiliale et le stalking
alors on peut tr dire ça comme le
tracage de ces victimes bonsoir Chantal
paulexier vous avez fondé votre
association en 1999 dans les ivelines à
morpa tout allait plutôt bien jusqu'à
quelques mois vous parlez maintenant
d'un dépôt de bilan éventuel d'une
fermeture pourquoi une telle situation
bah des problèmes comme beaucoup
d'associations liées à la crise et aux
baisses de subventions d'ailleurs bon
j'en profite pour vous remercier de
diffuser un peu notre appel à
mobilisation donc nous n'avons comme
solution que d'essayer effectivement de
sensibiliser les gens à la situation et
de trouver l'argent manquant pour
pouvoir
essayer de continuer à accueillir et
accompagner les victimes oui parce qu'il
y a un véritable besoin on va le voir
tout à l'heure il y a un paradoxe he les
demandes évoluent fortement sont en
hausse et pour autant vous manquez de de
fonds de subvention et l'avenir de cette
association agissait contre la violence
morale du côté de morpa et donc remis en
cause on va en parler tout à l'heure
avec vous restez en plateau avec nous
juste le temps de vous donner la suite
du programme de ce lundi il sera
notamment question forcément de sport
avec Anthony r bonsoir Anthony salut
wilfri alors ce soir qui recevons-nous
pour le sport et ben j'accueillerai tout
d'abord les dirigeants du du Sky rugby
ce weekend un match de gala chez le club
cinquantinois entre le Racing et le
Stade Français mais aussi du haut niveau
mais chez les jeunes mais aussi un
athlète plutôt exceptionnel Jean-Louis
HUD il a 73 ans et tenez-vous bien il
est recordman du monde du 1500 m 73 ans
on peut être champion du
monde on peut courir très vite et sans
doute plus vite plus vite que moi plus
vite que vous peut-être et enfin on
parlera de basket la reprise de de
trappe en National 2 ce sera dans une
quinzaine de minutes et puis également
en fin d'émission à noter he que je
recevrai alaingérard le directeur des
Jardins de Cocagne de Manil et amau on
vous en a déjà parlé sur cette antenne
nous parlerons du manger bio manger
solidaire nous sommes le 24 septembre
voici les titres de les titres en images
pardon les titres du jour le projet de
réaménagement de la gare routière de
Saint-Quentin les travaux avancent et
déjà se dessin le nouveau visage de ce
pgar nous allons faire le point dans un
instant un rally moto qui se transforme
en opération de prévention pour les deux
roues c'était à elle en cours atelier
test conseil de spécialistes ont ponctué
cette journée organisée par la police
nationale en fin de semaine dernière les
images également à découvrir au cours de
cette édition Les Jardins de Cocagne
justement une entreprise d'insertion qui
propose un retour à l'emploi par le
biais de l'agriculture vous entendrez
les témoignages de deux salariés Gérard
et Guy il nous expliqueront leur
quotidien et leurs espoirs et puis le
portrait de Véronique Coch une mordue de
course à pied à 53 ans cette assistante
de direction multiplie les palmarès
trois titres empochés lors des derniers
championnats
d'Europe la gare de Saint-Quentin a donc
décidé de faire pet neuve fin du
chantier mars 2013 déjà les changements
se dessine les quelques 70000 usagers
ont pu le constater sur place Alice
Gastine 10 millions d'euros c'est le
budget attribué à la rénovation de la
gare de Montini le Bretonneux construite
il y a 37 ans elle draîne près de 70000
usagers chaque j des travaux coûteux
mais nécessaires selon la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline principal investisseur avec la
SNCF il faut savoir que ici sur
cquanttin en iveline la gare juste
a-udessus on a près de 2000 mouvements
de bus par par jour on a 300 trains donc
il y avait nécessité de renforcer
l'accessibilité d'améliorer la
visibilité et d'améliorer d'une façon
plus globale le confort des voyageurs
sur les 100 millions d'euros alloués 6
millions sont pour la Salle des pas
perdu le reste va à la la partie liaison
c'est-à-dire entre les gares
ferroviaires et routières les taxis et
les voies piétonnes le calendrier est on
va dire strictement respecté pourquoi
parce queil s'inscrit dans une opération
globale d'aménagement urbain des
interventions ultérieures sur les abords
sur le site où nous sommes sont aussi
programmés dans un horizon de de 3 ans
ce nouveau pôle mise sur le transport
multimodal avec par exemple la location
de véhicules électriques et de vélo
livraison prévue de l'ensemble de la
gare en mars prochain les commerces
réouvriront quant à eux au cours de
l'année 2013